howdy guys I'm Von Miller and welcome to
the vcast here on the bleacher report
app this is a a very special show today
um I'm super excited about this one I
got one of my my favorite teammates and
one of my favorite people in life on the
show today um it is an honor and
privilege to have him on my show we got
Demar Hamlin my dog Bill safety um my
teammate um 2023 recipient of the George
how award and the NFL PA's Allen page
Community award W man I appreciate you
for coming my boy appreciate you having
me bro I know you I know you do a lot of
interviews like what's it been like
doing interviews and going on like the
media tour and doing all that stuff I've
been cool I feel like a part of it you
know like when you on the chase to get
into the league and you chasing
greatness to you know do everything you
want to accomplish in the league you
know that's kind of like a part of it
you know so like I always see myself
getting to this point some way no matter
what you know so we here now and it's
just more work work to be done man I
tell people all the time like playing
football is really the hard part like
all this other stuff that come with it
um media whether signing autographs or
appearances like that is that is the
easy part that is that's really like the
icing on the cake like you should always
be like energetic for that like it's
just the opportunity to like put your
name out man and you've taken you've
taken your opportunity you've made the
most of it man I know like uh before
like um last season like mid season I
had came to just like randomly I was
like theor bro like bro you playing well
like I thought you was a first I thought
you was a first round pick I told you
and Dane that just like just like
randomly bro and and to see you and and
your journey and for you to blow up man
like it's it's always good when the good
guys win when did you when did you fall
in love with football I fell in love
with football young as young as I
remember I started playing at
five I think I fell in love through my
dad you know
just pushing me to play wanting me to
play so you know once I got out there it
was it was a little natural my my first
year was like a little rough I remember
one time the coach told me stay home and
I was at safety and they scored a 60
yard touchdown on us the other way and I
just stood there like this what you told
me to do and watched the whole play yeah
like y'all told me stay home but yeah
man I I've been I've been in love with
the game young so I'm I'm I'm 20 years
in now so man that I remember my
earliest memories of of playing football
um I had to be like three or I had to be
three maybe even younger but you know
how when you're young you can barely
remember these these memories that you
have but this one I remember vividly I
don't know how old I was but I just
remember my dad screaming like I have
never heard him I'm only I'm young I'm
probably like three three you know two
and a half right in there I hear my dad
screaming and I run back there into his
room right and he's screaming he's
hollering I'm thinking like something's
wrong and I look at the TV and I see the
Cowboys like the star on a team I'm from
Dallas so he was watching the Cowboys
game and I'm guessing the Cowboys had
scored and he was yelling and I was
watching a little bit after that and
that was the moment for me I was like I
want to make my dad scream like this one
day and I fell in love with football and
this is really the only thing I've ever
wanted to do and that's lit bro to
really get there to really like get
there and and play I never I never I
knew I was going to make it to an NFL
but to to play in this capacity and be
on teams like this I never expected I
just had that belief in myself man and
you grew up in Pittsburgh did you want
to play for the Steelers did you always
want to go to to Pittsburgh
uh what is it the University of
Pittsburgh yeah yep University of
Pittsburgh uh so I I really what's crazy
is I never really seen myself going to
pit like when I first started getting
recruited when offer started rolling in
pit was like my second third offer
between pit pen State I got Temple first
during my sophomore year state
championship after the season I got pit
Penn State Ohio State and after I got
Ohio State they just started rolling in
like schools was coming into high school
just shaking my my hand like you got an
offer like not even trying to have a
conversation cuz they probably they felt
like they weren't going to get me um so
you know like Ohio State Notre Dame Penn
State they was kind of leading away
throughout my entire recruiting um in
just like a different category like the
programs was just different at the time
you know and then Nardi came to pit um
you know and he was just somebody that I
that you know he he was a defensive
coach he was just defensive coordinator
at Michigan State um he was coming in
bringing his defense he just had put
some Corners in the league from Michigan
State like two corners in the league
from Michigan State he just came home
and then um you know what I actually
think pulled me to pit a lot was Jordan
white hit safety from the Jets he was a
year ahead of me um like in high school
you know he was a close friend of mine
since we were like Dam Pittsburgh be
putting them out huh yeah Pittsburgh be
putting them in there putting them in
there so um he was like a year ahead of
me and we've been close since young like
little leagues uh his uncle used to come
get me from middle school and take me
out to they we used to play around and
then have aou practice and he would meet
my mom um back like closer to where I
lived so we've been close forever you
know so once he pulled the suggar and
went to pit and then had a successful
freshman year like he went freshman
All-American like he snapped on defense
so it was just kind of like it gave me
the vision you know what I mean and it
was just like he he kind of led the way
there so I I I lowke he followed in his
footsteps that's dope man yeah I went to
I went to T z&m like I you know I love T
z&m but I I want to go to other schools
like I to Florida checked out Florida
Old Miss it just felt like Texas ANM
just felt like home for me and that was
you know a lifetime of making decisions
you know some good some bad like going
to Texas A&M was definitely a good
decision for me man and going to
Pittsburgh was definitely a good
decision I actually uh I spent some time
down there on uh on on Texas ANM oh yeah
yeah what you think I used to have a um
a lady who who bran track down there
yeah do you do you ever wonder why we
don't have a national championship see
why not I don't see why not it's crazy
up there that thing is huge it's like
the architecture the whole campus it's
like d I don't know what's top of N and
it was great it was it was incredible
when I went there too this is like 2007
it was incredible when I went there too
but you know um did you ever imagine you
know going to Pittsburgh you know you
you said uh white head got you there did
you ever imagine that you would have a
day named after you though in Pittsburgh
July 9th Demar ham
day in the city of Pittsburgh what is
what is the mar hlin day like what is
the mar Hamlin day like man we
celebrated once they told me they was
giving me that day I I celebrated you
know what I mean and I won't say that I
I can't say I didn't picture it you know
what I mean I seen like growing up
watching Whiz Khalifa get his own Day
stuff like that like it just it it put
the bar in your back to like let's do
whatever it take to get it done so we
can you know uh achieve that type of
accomplishment in my city you know that
don't make me feel like I I left a
market in my city you know so to be able
to have a day I'm still waiting on a key
to my city you know that's kind of like
a a trophy too you know what I mean so
I'm still waiting on the key but to have
my own day that was that was like one of
those that's hard we made it moments I
you know I love holidays too I love
getting with my fam and and my friends
back home and like kicking it we got a
holiday back in Dallas too and it's just
it's just amazing it's amazing to really
bring out the city and have like the
kids playing and food barbecuing and
loud music like January July 9th that's
right after 4th of July bro it's going
to be lit that's a perfect Vibe um
chasing I remember last year I was
asking you about it you was wearing like
the chasing M's gear and I was like man
can you can you make me like a a a
spin-off like chasing bees chasing
billions and you was like bro yeah I get
it yeah I get it I feel so crazy like I
should have just took the chasing M Stu
bro I I should have just chasing I
should have just took the chasing M cuz
then it like blew up then it like blew
up and like I still haven't like I still
haven't received any like you know we
ain't come on here empty-handed that's
you know we came to you
today brought you the whole collection
you know what I
mean good Pittsburgh that's that's the
Pittsburgh hoodie watch you some sweats
my dog got got they stack sweats he got
the chasing M's uh chasing M rug right
in front of his in front of his locker
he's the only only Locker in the locker
room with a rug and it say chasing M's
bro it's so lit love me before they all
d That's
hard you design all this yourself yeah I
do bro it's like it's like my piece away
from the game for real so I just
whatever time downtime I got I'm I'm
doing this I brought you two of these
too they kind of they fit different so
you'll figure it out that's hard bro I
appreciate you man I know Marne she
would
love to yeah yeah I I got one for you
there there's something in there for you
where I remember it and it's and it's
and it's dope it's it's dope [__] too
like I remember we I forgot what game we
was at but um
Tain taine edmans he had on like this
this sweatsuit right and I went I was
like bro like what is that like it's it
looked like high fashion I was like bro
what is that what is that Chrome Hearts
like what is that boy he said no this
this this dear this is uh this is Chason
I was like bro I got to get me some man
main was a big supporter he he stayed
putting it on yeah but you know it's
it's I try to really make it like a
combination of all of my worlds where
it's like I'm in the high fashion and
I'm in the like the Earth Urban drip you
know what I mean but also like athletic
wear and you know just tapping into the
whole Lane of just being an athlete as
well you know we all we need all type of
accessories and things like that so you
know I'm trying to Branch all of those
gaps together in the one thing with my
brand you know man it's it's dope to to
wear your stuff too like to wear
something that you design I got the I
got the triple V hats and stuff and like
just to be able to wear your stuff not
nobody else's stuff not like Chrome
hearts or Gucci it's like your stuff and
it like hit harder especially when I'm
wearing my stuff and I'm wearing like my
teammate stuff it has like this this
level of uh exclusivity to it that can't
nobody get they always see it but they
can't get it and you you was you was one
of the first to to really get that going
man and it's not only a clothing brand
it's a foundation as well what uh tell
us more about that yeah so you know I
got the for profit side which is the
clothing and the rugs and things like
that and you know I got the nonprofit
side as well you know just giving back
to the community that's something I you
know I wanted to do all along like you
say watching the kids play in the bouncy
houses all that you know that I was that
kid that was what my dad was doing for
the community back in the day like
through something called feed the hood
days you know what I mean so he would
have the bouncy houses out he would have
the basketball going through on three
tournaments somebody's on the grills hot
dogs hamburgers everything you can
imagine you know it's just bringing the
whole Community together in a way that
nobody else was doing it you know what I
mean and he was from down the hill in a
manner my mom was from up the hill so he
would do it in both places yeah so like
just to grow up in that atmosphere and
see how you know it made me feel having
those days waiting on him hearing
everybody talking about it people
getting outfits for the days things like
that the competition of the kids of the
basketball tournaments whatever it may
be um you know it just put that fuel in
me to really you know just want to make
it to do my part and give and give back
to the community so soon as I got out of
college like this was before nil so you
know you couldn't make any type of money
in college so
once I declared for the draft first
thing I did was you know set up my
foundation with my agent and then you
know I set up a GoFundMe link and I'm I
think I wanted like $2,500 just to be
able to do a a toy drive and think I put
it together in like N9 10 days before
before Christmas before I left to go
train um and it was a success you know
so we just kept it going and you know I
had I had visions of you know doing that
every year and eventually building up to
do more things you know but now with the
opportunity and all the love that came
in you know the the opportunities are
endless and the impact that we can make
in the communities across the world not
even just my own communi just endless so
I'm excited for my my life forever after
that's that's that's hard man like I
think I know I think I know what it
means like because I feel like I can
relate just by seeing chasing M on
anything like it really hit home for me
I feel like I can relate to it but I
wanted to like you know get it from you
like what is what does chasing M's like
mean what is what is the meaning by
behind it I feel like I I feel like I
know I feel like I know but just for the
audience at home yeah you get it you
know because you on that journey and
you've like you've been on the journey
surpass the journey over and over again
you know but for the people that you
know don't know it's chasing millions
and it's it's really like the motto
behind having a dream having a vision
you know and it's the Journey of getting
into that Vision so you know the process
of putting work in whatever the dream
may be putting the work in staying down
staying committed staying focused and
achieving it you know so you can change
the the atmosphere the environment for
everyone around you um it was something
I started in high school as just a
slogan I would just hashtag on all my
pictures of like just a way of telling
myself I'm a make it to the NFL you know
to make whatever money to be able to
move my mom out of her house whatever it
may be and you know my friends latched
on to it it was a group thing it was all
of us it was our group message name and
it was just our way of just showing our
unity and our mission you know we was
all on the same Mission trying to get
recruited trying to get offers to be
able to make it to the league
and so it started out as just a hashtag
it was just a hashtag so I went into
college and I got injured I had three
surgeries my freshman year uh sports
hernia all sports hernia surgeries and
it was just like I couldn't figure it
out I couldn't figure it out I knew I
had what it takes to make it to the
league but it was like I didn't't know
if the opportunity was going to come
because I was I was injured I didn't
seen it before with people happen so I'm
like man I got to do something to stay
afloat I I got to do something so first
thing I did I ran to the mall uh went
into the little stores where they print
t-shirts I bought a T-shirt and I put
the the Chas and M's logo on a on a on a
shirt and I wore it back to it was in
the middle of Camp yeah I wore it back
to camp and uh all of my teammates it
was just catching fire all of my
teammates they were loving it and so I'm
like all right I got to get them in some
stuff you know so I started getting my
teammates and some stuff and I started
selling stuff and it just started
catching fire and as I just got back on
my feet and playing again I'm just like
you know this is just another blessing
God sent me that I'm going just keep
going with man that's that's hard man
I'm a huge believer in manifestation
especially when you write it down not
like hoping something happened not like
wishing something happen but truly
believing and truly having that Vision
like something that happened bro like
you just described it bro like writing
it down and then making hoodies like it
just took off from there man like
chasing M's making it the NFL was that
that was always your your dream to make
it to the NFL yeah that was always that
was always playing Numero Uno you know
like that was always my biggest dream as
far as I can remember you know only
other dream as a kid that I even crossed
my mind as a career was like creating
like hotel chains you can still do that
chasing M's hotel that would be tough
you know what I mean chasing M's Hotel
like cities everybody GNA stop through
for sure man it could be like the
boutique hotel where like you got like
20 30 rooms and like it's always booked
up like an exclusive club for for for
certain members you know what I mean
that'll be tough that'll be tough we we
could put one of those in Buffalo
that'll be dope that would be that'll be
what did you so what did you think when
you got drafted to
Buffalo so my whole draft process you
know being in Pittsburgh and dealing
with the cold every year I'm like all
right God got me like I got to be going
some like I done stayed down I done did
everything I done made my bed every day
like God got me I'm I'm going somewhere
warm you know and uh like I had well
Ohio state was one of like my biggest
recruiters and that was like when Urban
Meyer was the head coach and they just
won a national championship and then he
had just got the job at Jacksonville um
so the defensive coordinator was the
safeties coach at the time so like he
was big on me um as I was coming out on
the draft just like you know we we
wanted you out of high school uh so you
know I'm like ah they might be coming to
get me you know what I mean so so I mean
things work out for a reason when I
first got drafted to Buffalo I was a
little upset at first at the fact that I
sat on the board for so long you know I
felt like I was going to go a little bit
earlier everyone think they going to go
a little bit earlier but um you know
just watching my name set up on like the
the last left since like the second
round I'm like like I was just like
ready to ready to just like show
everybody that they you know what they
missed out on so like you know for the
first 30 minutes I was I was super like
you know ready to just do something I
couldn't wait to get up there but you
know once that settled in I was I was
super excited to get up here and once I
got up here it was just like nothing but
love it's it's the closest thing to
Pittsburgh too like as far as city-wise
it's it's it's nothing but love here man
I I love buffalo I was the same way I
was like please let me go somewhere
where it's where it's warm but if you
really think about it no matter who you
play for you're GNA have to play Nico
like you might play you might get you
know three or four games more you know
in the war in the warmth but yeah either
way half of the season is in the cold no
matter who you play you can play for
Miami but if you look at the divisional
teams you got to go to Buffalo you got
to go to you got to play to New England
you got to go to New York like all the
games all you going to have to play in
the cod in NFL what was your first
impression on a team when you got
here all love it was super all love and
it was similar atmosphere from what I
was coming from you know just being a
HomeTown kid and then a captain on the
team and a leader um you know it was
kind of like my energy in the locker
room you know and getting up here was
like all love everybody was supportive
everybody was helpful um it was urgency
but it was like no competition with each
other so it's like everybody's urgent
within their own process and like what
they trying to accomplish but nobody was
hating or downplaying or looking at
somebody else like competition to where
like and it happens though I ain't going
to help you yeah that happens I done
seen it in college and stuff like that
you know and everyone that has came into
the team from other places always say
like it's not like this everywhere else
so cherish this like you this being your
first team and like you know you got a
long way to go in this league cherish
this right here because this ain't
everywhere yeah so that's something I
appreciate as well you know you don't
you don't get that everywhere you know
we all but we all up here together you
know what I mean this all we this is all
we got this is all we got you know thank
God they got great food here and and
it's for me like I got two kids I got
two kids um I think probably if I was
was if this was 22 year old van and you
know it' probably be different but where
I am in my life like this is perfect for
me I got a great football team I got two
little boys I love to play golf I play
video games and you know they got all of
that here for me man and and on top of
that like Bill's the mafia is is
incredible here I like I I love bills
mafia they they are incredible man what
is uh what was your first experience
with Bill's
Mafia my first experience was just on
Twitter after the draft you know just
seeing how they were just flowing in
like to all of the draft picks and just
showing nothing but love um it was like
a reaction that I didn't even expect you
know like being a late round draft pick
you know it's usually like only
attention on the on the first few or or
the first one you know but it it was
just like everything was just catching
fire they were they were just I was
loving their energy they was loving mine
as well you know so once I got up here
and then got to
experience playing in the stadium and
practicing in the stadium it was just
like yeah this is this is a different
place this is a different place it's
it's dope man it's dope man like I fell
in love with with the Buffalo Bills for
me it was training camp like I started
to see like these fans are like for real
but then after the first game and we
played the Tennessee Titans I think it
was it was probably Monday Night
Football second G and I was driving to
the stadium and like they was they had
like a little booth and they was they
was like on the sign and said free Von
Miller haircuts here like everybody was
they was giving out the triangle I was
like I was like this place is I was like
I was like this this place is dope man
like I always had love for like the
bills like I thought I was going to go
to the Buffalo Bills like last minute
the Denver bronos took me so it was kind
of like a you know it's kind of like a
spot there for me like man Buffalo is
dope man I I love that environment I
love the team I love how they The
Underdogs all always I love that Vibe
but getting here and um really
experience it like my love for the
Bill's Mafia and the fans that we have
is definitely grown and I'm sure for you
your love for Bill's Mafia has
definitely grown uh for real for real
the fans donated over $6.7 million to
your foundation um Following last season
what did that what did that mean to you
could you and could you ever have
imagined that you would have that type
of support I'm I'm sure you did I'm sure
you did I'm sure you imagine that I mean
that that that blows any imagination out
the water for real you know like what
what did that mean to you though uh it
meant the world to me like you know know
bills Mafia standing up in my you know
my biggest time of need you know like
that's those are the moments you
remember for life you know when you when
you need people the most them showing up
for you you know and for them to show up
like that it was just like you know they
are who I thought they were you know
I've seen it time and time again over
you know them doing it I remember them
um donating to somebody from my hometown
Tyler boy who's actually on the Bengals
um Foundation I think back in 2018 when
he like scored a winning touchdown I put
them into the playoffs MH like that's
not even no that's not even their own
you know but them just reaching out like
showing support for him you know just
because they got their teams in playoffs
he not even on team they donated like
250,000 if I'm not mistaken but like
that's just crazy you know and I one
thing I appreciate them I appreciate
bills Mafia for is they lean into like
their unique players and their players
with personality and things like that
you know they support everyone but they
lean into them like to see people giving
free haircuts and them giving out the
triangle that's different you know what
I mean do like they support whatever
their players are into like fans show up
to games when teams are winning
everywhere you know in every city but I
think like what separates bills Mafia is
the fact that they show up for their
players off the field and like what
their players are interested in off the
field you know what I mean they seen
that I was trying to give back to the
community and any way possible so they
like you know we they returned the favor
for me so like it's that was all love I
appreciate that all love and it's real
love here like you said fans love their
team and they going to show up but the
love from bills Mafia like it's real
unconditional genuine love not only for
bills Mafia but anybody that helps out
like you said with Tyler Boyd they they
donated money to his charity they they
donated money to Andy Dalton's charity
as well I think they beat the S they
beat the Chargers they beat the Chargers
that going to the playoffs and like
bills Mafia went crazy because they
needed Cincinnati to beat the Chargers
to get in and they just man they I love
bills Mafia and it's dope to hear you
love Bill bills Mafia too earlier this
year you partnered with the American
Heart Association and launched the
chasing M's CPR tour tell us a little
bit about that what was your inspiration
behind it um you know well partnering
with the aha I I had met them uh early
February I think early February we had a
dinner in a hotel in Buffalo where I met
the CEO Nancy Brown who's like one of my
closest friends now I I love her we talk
on almost every week even outside of
working together you know but just
building relationships man and she's
she's super special but she cared about
impact in the hard space and they've
been making an impact for years on years
on years you know so once I got the
opportunity to sit down with them and
they got to understand me and that you
know I would show so much love through
my situation that I wanted to make an
impact as well so you know we we
partnered on a lot of things we
brainstormed a lot of ideas and you know
once we kindly came up with the CPR tour
we wanted to in the cities that impacted
me the most you know and obviously
Pittsburgh my hometown Buffalo where I
play and then Cincinnati um where
everything happened and um we we we hit
the ground running we started here in
Buffalo where we gave out 50 aeds to all
the youth sports leagues and you know we
got I think up to, 1500 people uh CPR
train hands only CPR trained and then we
went to Pittsburgh and did the same
thing I think it was a thousand people
got CPR trained and we gave out 50 plus
aeds to all of the US sports teams and
which my brother is playing in them and
things like that so it was just super
special to be home and we actually did
that on the uh Demar Hamlin day too um
so that was that was like a a real good
moment right there for me and then going
up to Cincinnati um before we came
before we went up to Rochester for for
camp and did the same thing 1500 and
gave out 50 aeds um so we we started off
to a strong start you know what I mean
and I'm super excited for for
2024 uh oh I can't leave out when we
went to London um did y did it over
there too oh that's dope you know yeah
just brainstorming with the uh with
Nancy man I'm like I want to take it
International and London came about you
know um and so once we went to London
you know it presented the opportunity to
be able to go over there and make some
impact as well so day before we play me
and my Foundation we set up an event
found the location got in touch with
like all of the American Football sports
teams over there and we gave all some
ads and you know we got everyone who
came CPR trained and it was like super
dope it was it was it was you know it
was I can't even like recreate that
feeling of like being in a whole entire
different country and being able to like
feel like you leaving your mark that was
like I like that feeling so I can't wait
till next year man it's it's it's got to
be dope man you know going through your
journey and you know all the things that
you've overcome to be able to help you
know children um give and to be able to
give them access to you know save lives
has got to be dope I'm CPR train I'm CPR
trained too yeah I'm CPR train too
whether it's the the ad or like toddlers
or adults like took a class with my
assistant right before my son was born
and I'm CPR trained as well um bro is
there is there another tour in the works
yeah no doubt touring is fun man yeah
let me let me know whenever you going on
tour again
man hey let me know man yeah man we so
no location truly set up up yet but just
brainstorming some ideas right now but
one that really sits on on me heavy is
like I want to do something and be able
to go in Africa and be able to make an
impact and you know Switzerland like you
know I want to tour and and be able to
go and you know search out and look look
for some places that need help the most
you know and be able to go over there
and just make some impact and also just
to be able to just explore the world
like you said touring is fun I love
sightseeing I love seeing and learning
new places so you know also I'll be you
know make an impact I'll be able to like
you know explore the world hang out man
see y yall see why I love this guy man I
told y'all man like you know he's is a
special person on and off the football
field and everything about him is about
other people being able to help other
people being able to change lives and
you know it's just incredible you know
to be to be his teammate and it's
incredible to have you on my show man
love bro I love you you know I love the
the chasing M's tour the chasing M CPR
tour had to be fun but the offseason
tour had to be fun fun as well you know
going to Michael Ruben's white party you
know going to Courtside games talk about
that man talk about the the fun Side and
being able to experience so many
different things man the offseason was
like a a super Journey that just taught
me so much about life man it it really
taught me that relationships are
everything you know and relationships
are real you know and actually showing
up for for people you know it it it
matters it matters in life you know so
you know Michael Rubin was kind of one
of the first people that really contact
me and he might have been one of the
first people I actually got on the phone
with in the hospital you know he just he
just truly cares about sports he truly
cares about people um and you know he's
been a genuine friend uh if nothing else
you know ever since you know my incident
and you know uh through him you know
I've got to I've got to have a lot of
fun I've got to learn a lot of business
um I've got to learn a lot about you
know running a company I've got a lot of
meet I've got to meet a lot of great
people you know the white party was was
like how was it man how long come on man
let us know man when did you make it
when did you make it in after that I saw
you worked out the next day too yeah of
course no no no the white party was in
the white party was uh it was it was
July 1st if I'm not mistaken it was July
1st so I had the I threw out the pitch
for the um I threw out the pitch for the
Yankees actually I did an event I did a
CPR event with the Yankees that's dope
so my I had a crazy I had a crazy day
that day so I I started my day in New
York and um did an event with the
Yankees I went to Yankee Stadium I met
all the Yankees uh everyone you know got
CPR trained before the game yeah so went
back to the hotel rested up a little bit
and then came back to the stadium for
the game throughout the first pitch and
you know stayed for a little bit watched
the game and it was like right after I
forget the pitcher's name but he had
just pitched a no hitter the night
before so like stadium was packed so it
was like hell of an experience and then
um and you threw out the first pitch H
yeah yeah did you give like one of the
the lobs or did you try to like I I so I
I did I did two first pitures I did one
for the the Pirates my home team and
that's when I tried to do the lob and
they make it so the Yankees I'm like all
right I got to throw it you know so I
tried to beam it down there I tried to
beam it down there my pitch wasn't too
bad but um white party I think started
at 5 and the the baseball game was at
seven so I was already like I felt
conflicted you know I felt conflicted
but I'm like you know like Mike's a
businessman you know like he he going to
understand like I got to handle this
business before I come have some fun you
know and he truly did and he truly
helped me out even getting there you
know the Hamptons is I think it's a I'm
not how three-hour drive from New York
maybe I'm not sure so he ful a
helicopter in for me so that made it
what an hour it made it like 40 minutes
40 minutes he flew the helicopter in for
me I flew straight to the Hamptons got
picked up by the driver switched my fit
on the on the heli uh hopped in a ride
went straight to the party man it was
just like it was like pulling up it felt
like Will Smith and Fresh Prince like
pulling up pulling up to his crib and
just seeing all my favorite people like
you know through him I got to meet Meek
which is like I really look at him like
a big brother you know like he just
always just gives me like some some he
always say the things my dad would say
like everything my dad would say you
know he just even like yeah you handled
that right even by just doing what I had
to do before I came here like yeah you
handled that right you know and he just
always make sure like making sure my
head on straight like if I'm ever in a
room he going he checking my energy so
and I I appreciate that like it's
something small but I I appreciate that
for sure you know but man I I met some I
met some good people there little baby
which I actually met little baby at um
uh Michael Ruben's dinner in um Super
Bowl so that was like that was fire I
sat next to him the owner of Tik Tok
yeah uh Travis Scott which is like you
know people might not see it but like
he's one of the biggest businessmen in
the world like he's he's always thinking
about just trying to leverage his
situation and just trying to like truly
grow his business and and grow
everything and you know he he got he he
got his hand in almost everything the
music the clothing shoes like like
everything you know so I'm just I'm just
being a sponge anytime I'm around all
these people because like outside of
like you know what they do as far as
their talent even athletes or music or
whatever it may be like everyone is like
business-minded first you know and they
let everything follow after so you you
met you basically met everybody you
basically you basically met everybody
but are there any people that you were
surprising me or like when you met him
like it was like dope like like dang
like I I met this person like this is
cool is it anybody like that I'm sure
like after a while it started to get
regular I got a full list man I got a
full list uh like Jay Bieber you know
what I mean like Justin Bieber meeting
Justin Bieber at the white party was
kind of like you know we I grew up on
Bieber like I remember seeing Bieber's
first song getting like you know seeing
them through now but just to meet him
and him just being like a regular dude
like like same way that how we just kick
it up and bust it like he he's one of
them so I was just enjoying that as well
um like I say Meek that's another person
that I like you know related to my whole
life coming up um you know through his
journey he kind of like spoke for me uh
Rob wave I just met R wave the other day
that was coner pittsbur that was that
man I couldn't wait for that moment I
really couldn't wait for that moment um
man me and you that was that that was
that was a crazy moment bro you know
just getting you on the team bro getting
you on the team and just being able to
just you know become a brother with you
that was I you know I can't take that
for granted bro like that's something
that mean a lot like playing a game with
my brother like that's something he
still talks about I'll let him run back
his P whenever you get ready man I'll
let him run back that Madden game
whenever he get ready feel like you got
out on him so
he yeah shout out little bro to like I
like I'm huge on family too and whenever
I see you with your little brother your
mom your dad like I'm the I'm the same
way bro like I'm got a super close
family my brother my mom and my dad we
talk every day my brother just had a son
man so to see you had that had that type
of relationship with your with your
little brother man it's super cool man
super crazy off season but somehow you
you was able to humble yourself stay
down to earth and then you was able to
go full circle and play football again
like how was that how was you know how
was it you know playing football doing
all this stuff training getting ready
training getting ready to to make your
return to football and actually making a
return and then seeing seeing playing
time in the Miami game uh man it was
tough it was it was tough at first you
know just even making decision to like
you know come back into the game and and
like you know once you make that
decision there ain't no half stepping
you know I mean like it ain't no half
stepping like you you come out on that
field and you and you thinking about too
much or you playing timid that's how you
get hurt you know so um I had to truly
lock back in and and and Go With It full
throttle um you know and I spent a lot
of the Year trying to just get away from
the game and just enjoy life again you
know
so I gave myself the time I needed
really the time I needed just to just to
clear my mind and and actually get ready
for you know a season it takes so much
coming into a season each year so you
know not that we back into it you know
I'm I'm fully focused my mind is focused
on the right things I'm you know I'm in
my grind I'm in my I'm in my like my
consistent window of just doing the
right things and just letting them pay
off you know so you know I'm staying
ready I'm staying ready it's a long
season I didn't seen it last year you
know happen where you know you when your
numberers called you got to be ready you
know so I'll be I'll be ready again just
like I was last year yeah I'm I'm huge
on mindset and you know like even if
these cameras weren't here I like I'll
still be trying to you know check hey
how you how you feeling just it's just
football this this what you do man and
like you know for you every time would
like check with you you already I could
just see it in your eyes like you was
already 10 steps past that man yeah I I
tell everybody that bro you know like
when they ask me about different things
I tell them like you somebody that's
super big on just checking in on me and
just just checking my energy and I
always just making sure my mentals in
the right space and just like even if
it's just like like like you said like
it's just football it like that' be
going a long way and even like the other
day when we talked about like you know
no matter how you feeling like you
already won like that just put
everything back back into perspective
for me that
like what can you trip about you know
what I mean like when you already won
when you already run you ain't you ain't
worrying about the mistakes or whatever
whatever the case may be you know you
already it's like you already beat the
game and like you just going back for
like the skins and like the extra
achievements like after the game that's
that's what you doing right now man the
Bills Mafia we talked about bills Mafia
several times during this uh podcast how
was the how was the reception when you
came back bro like I know you always
felt a love but this had to be special
it had to be a special moment to get
back on the football field and build
some mind for you to receive you the way
they did how did that feel man super
special moment it it it's been a it's
been a super special ride um since I
came back to the game last year um when
we played the Bengals in the playoffs
you know all the way till up till today
you know it's been the same feeling same
reaction you know from bills Mafia all
all love all support you know everyone
just kind of just you know they they
support they support my courage they
support my strength um they support me
you know being able to just get knocked
just get back up when you get knocked
down man that's and that's where life's
about like that's that's that's life's
journey it's going to happen to
everybody it's like the inevitable you
know what I mean but you got to yeah you
got to keep rolling with the punches no
matter what so you know I'm just in my
journey I'm just in my journey and I
appreciate them for just all the support
and the love cuz like that just that
just gives you the fuel to keep going
man not only builds Mafia but our team
like we just got to special team man
they rally around like everybody whether
it was Micah getting injured whether
it's Jordan porer like driving all the
way to KC just so he can play in the
game we always get behind our guys man
and our teammates they really got behind
you still to this day they still get
behind you as well too let's shed a
little light on our teammates how does
how does it feel to get the love from
the team man I swear being up here in
Buffalo is like my piece away from the
world you know just being with the team
like once I first got back with the team
at OTAs I got like a a release relief
off my shoulders and just like a like a
home feeling that like I a get no other
place other than going home to my mom's
house you know what I mean but it's just
like everybody has just done a like a
amazing job just like comforting me and
protecting me from the outside world you
know and and just being respectful in my
space at the same time that you know
like it's it's it's nothing but Brothers
on a team you know it's it's a truly
unique and special place man like
everybody don't hesitate you know to
come talk to me come ask me questions
come you know check on my energy um
regardless of anything man I'm
appreciative of that you know like I'm
not the only one that's going through
something on the team you know like
everybody has their own issues going on
so you know I always try to put that in
perspective as well and that also allows
me to like let go of my own problems and
things as well cuz like we all in it
together we all got our own stuff going
on but you know when we here we focused
on this so like you know just keeping
that in perspective and then still even
realizing that everybody got whatever
they got going on but you know know
everybody still making sure that they
check up on me you know it it just kind
of like it it makes me even want to be a
better person you know what I mean and
just being able to have so many like
vets to learn from and then just to like
ask questions like I don't feel like
there's nothing in the world that I
can't know learn like get some knowledge
from by asking somebody under our roof
you know what I mean and that's like
like I don't think everybody can say
that like I think there's somebody that
I can ask a question to on the team
about anything and the world and they
going to have the answers and they going
to like be willing to share the
information as well so like that's
that's a special feeling and I'm just
I'm glad to be a part of that I'm glad
to be like a piece of that man I I would
definitely agree that from the top down
from from my from my owner Terry Terry
Pula and you know our GM the Brandon
Bean he's he's a special person like he
really is he he goes out of his way man
and you know from Josh Allen to our
practice squad guys like everybody is so
involved in this team and they always
trying to find a way to um to help us
win like everybody knows their roles and
they do their role and they do more and
they um that that has the makings to to
be a very special team we're already a
very special team we just got to go out
there and get the accolades are short
but now it's time to play a game you
want to play a game let's get it I got
so this game that we have here is team
superlatives right you remember like in
a in U in the yearbook at the end of the
year oh yeah yeah yeah yeah most most
likely what did I get in high school I
think I got like most likely to be
successful definitely for sure
definitely for sure bro like we we'll
play a game right here man and just
along those lines bro we got like some I
ready I I say what we what we doing I
and then you just write which
teammate you think this would be all
right bet so number one would be king of
trash
talk
and whenever you ready we'll show them
all right let's get it
ready I would say I I would say t crane
too but I wrote Diggs but now I'm
thinking about it too I would write
Diggs and Josh because they like bro
they like that game when we played the
Rams last year like to see to see to see
to see go back and forth with with jayen
and then see Josh go at jayen too like
you know I'll put those two on there
they both the kings of trash so but
crane but crane Shaq is up there too you
right though cuz I I love when Josh is
in that mode though like when he just in
that mode and he talking his stuff out
there while he doing his while he doing
his one too like that's when I know he's
really in that mode so but Shaq that's
somebody who off the field on the field
always always every day crane crane
going he going to talk his stuff to
every walking past in the
building all right only two I got most
likely to fall asleep in a
meeting
oh hold on let me think you know our
meetings be serious JB ain't playing
around
uh let me
see you going like this one
who you br man my myself I don't know
what it is going right me too I swear I
swear I don't know what it is from my
earliest memories of like playing
football and going to the meeting room
and like having film session after like
from day one I always used to fall
asleep in there and it hasn't changed
like year 13 like it's even it's even
worse now like I it it only take me like
15 seconds like i' be watching I'll be
locked in and then all of a sudden
dreaming like I'm dreaming it's like
there is no getting drowsy or nothing
it's like I'm watching and now I'm
Dreaming it's like instant yeah bro I'm
Mr Kinga stand up in the meeting because
like I don't even got time to be just
sitting down just being tired and my
coach just even noticing me like
drifting off so I I don't I don't care
bro I'll get up and stand I'll walk
around the back of the room I'll just
switch my seat get up start stretching
anything just to stay up like I try and
I see in the front too so coach
Washington you
right and i s in the front too then in
our defense meeting room like I'm I'm
right when I start getting woozy like
I'll look down and Shaq could be looking
up at me he like hey tired boy you TI
like yeah I am I am tired bro I am tired
we just got we do a few more man this
one is most likely to break the internet
with their pregame
fit I think we all know who this one
is
really
yeah hey my boy I I was going to say me
too but Diggs he kill it he kill it
every time I was going to say you and
digs you know that commercial that
that's one of my favorite commercials
funny bro super funny shooting that
commercial bro it was hilarious bro like
just even from when we like sat down
like and it was just like it was just
like a idea like we on like the Zoom
call talking to like the progressive
people like going over stuff and like
you know digs he take like it's serious
right and I'm and I I've done I've done
a couple commercial he's done a couple
of commercials so I knew like it was
supposed to be about comedy right and
the first like draw up that we had right
um it was like a cowboy hat and like
some overalls and it was like all of
these colors and stuff and I was like
yeah it's cool don't matter to me D like
no
no he was like n like they was like No
And they was like it's it's it's
supposed to be for lab he was like yeah
but you know I I'm not going to you know
I'm not up there to be a clown like he's
like I really take this serious like
I'll be in fashion week and I was like
okay we listen it don't matter to me we
y'all make sure y get something that
that he then that gold the gold outfit
that's something that like he were from
the change yeah yeah y both I put you
because you know you remember you got
the outfit from Beyonce that thing was
everywhere that was Beyonce I appreciate
you yeah that's tough shout out to
Beyonce and the beehive that man that's
tough oh my God U two
more most likely to forget their
cleats
see uh who Amma
go who Amma
go
ready hey you switch your mouth so many
times though I would say I always say it
bro like it
like that would be that would be
something would just be like man man my
man he has so many other things on his
mind like and his priorities he wants to
be the best football player he could
possibly be and he has he has his
mindset set on that he will get that so
I can definitely see him like forgetting
his cleat cuz his mind is just somewhere
else and on top of that he's he's a
character like he's one of the he's one
of the the personalities that we have on
our team that makes our locker room like
so unique it really does yep I say
myself because I'm always forgetting
something I'm always losing something I
probably lost something in here already
like that's just me brother I lose I
lose my cell phone daily I lose my cell
phone daily um in the last one most
likely to be on a reality TV
show I would say Dawson man like he just
has that he just has like that that Jack
harlo like personality of he kind of
looks like Jack Carlo too he just has
like this TV show this actor personality
about him man I can definitely see him
like on a reality TV show like thugging
it out Dawkins oh yeah of course I say
do do though because do do just got like
a big personality he know how to he know
how to work the room he know how to you
know just control the entire atmosphere
so like you know D do he got the
personality to do it everybody would
love Mr snow he he he would love that do
for sure man doc I could definitely see
him on a TV show for sure let's go to
our our our win versus the bcks man we
have been you know we have been thugging
out a couple of games and you know to
get a a big win versus the Bucks it was
huge for us um five and three Midway
through the season um you're in the
locker room you you hear all type of
speeches that we get from coach mcder
but the one after the game it kind of
had everybody internet like up in arms
like what did that mean he said quote he
said that's what I'm used to seeing
probably the first time other than maybe
in episodes of the Raiders game and
again in the Miami game where it looked
like every play wasn't an adventure what
do you think he meant by that every play
wasn't an
adventure you know I just think he means
that like we're such a special team and
you know when we're playing to the
ability that we can play I think that's
the adventure that he's talking about
you know so every play can really be a
big play every play can kind of be like
that that play for that's going to be
shown on Sports Center all week you know
what I mean when we're when we're
hitting on all cylinders when we're
playing you know complimentary football
that's when we playing our best you know
so I think that's what he means you know
we play we play we play dominant versus
the Raiders and we play very well versus
the Dolphins you know so you know I I
think I think that's exactly what he
means what you think when I when I
reflect on it and I just look at some of
the plays like I can see like some like
especially some of these drives that
we've had like um in the New England
game like we had to go like score to you
win the game and then we we put together
a drive with Josh then we win the game
and then we it looks like we're GNA win
the game and then we let the Patriots
like do a little flat pass down the
field and it comes down to the end of
the game and I think that he saying that
it doesn't have to be like that it don't
it doesn't have to be an adventure we
could just go out there and do what we
do and not make it so interesting even
though it's it's I mean it gets my it
gets my heart rate it gets my heart rate
bumping for sure like but it is
stressful man it is I I can I like now
reflecting on it like I see like
especially some of the the games that
we've had it it doesn't have to be like
that we could just go out there and play
our style of football and be over and
done with it and not not make it
competitive Josh Allen in that game he
had 31 completions 342 yards three
touchdowns um donin K went crazy he had
his first uh his first touchdown in the
NFL how do you see him progressing uh I
see him progressing very well you know
from the day that he got here I seen
like what his what his role was and I I
played GM a little bit and I'm like okay
I see what we was doing you know I see
what we was doing he you know he's super
shifted he could get open in space you
know kind of like that that Travis
Kelsey s type type of style play you
know what I mean so just to see him keep
progressing and and get to see like the
dog that he is you know that's I think
that's one thing that I that I I noticed
from him just watching is he a dog he a
dog he he catch that ball he turn around
he's trying to run somebody over he
KN yeah he Ain trying to let the first
person tackle him and he's got for short
hands like I don't think I seen him yeah
he I don't see him drop a ball you know
so I'm super excited to have him as a
teammate I love competing against him in
practice and you know I'm just super
super excited to keep seeing this
progression man I I'm excited but I'm
not really surprised and I'm not really
like satisfied either though because
I've seen the kid in practice like close
up like I know like what he can do I've
seen him jump like at least 40 inches in
the air and go catch a ball like I've
seen him like get the ball and and turn
up the field I've seen him catch the
ball like mid stride and cut up the
field and next time you know he 30 yards
down field I've I've I've seen it and so
like I'm excited for him but I'm not
surprised nor satisfied because I know
like I know like what he can be maybe I
don't know maybe I don't want to put a
limit on him but I know like he he
deserves to be in the upper etch Lon of
of tight ends for sure no doubt speaking
of GM Demar you know I like to be GM Von
at the at the deadline we we went crazy
we added a couple of pieces um we added
Leonard fette um to the offense um we
added rasul Douglas um Lenny uh I feel
like Lenny's been on my team before like
cuz I I like I just I've been around him
and I've seen him out and I've talked to
him on Instagram talked to him in person
like he's coming to he's coming to Von
Miller day and he's been around so many
different times like I feel like I know
I feel like he's been on my team before
but this is his first time officially
being on my team like what do you think
about the addition of of playoff Lenny
uh I love it you know what's crazy is me
and him actually had a conversation
about it um um in the spring um we were
both at uh Steph's so like charity
basketball game and we were on the same
team and you know he just kind of
mentioned it to me or I might have
mentioned it to him however it happened
you know but we had that conversation
and you know we got to spend a little
bit of time around each other there and
um you know he somebody that I've
watched a long time I remember seeing
them you know like the number one
running back in the under arour game or
whatever it may be he still that though
he still that super still at you know
super still at you know but um been able
to see his progression you know through
every level and you know what's crazy is
like I think I dm'd him years ago like
when I seen him as you know top athlete
in high school I'm in middle school or
whatever seeing him progress on the
college I think I dm'd him like like you
know your story inspir me whatever he
hit me back um as a young you know so
like just like I appreciate the little
things in life you know I mean just him
being who he was at the time hitting me
back that meant everything to me like I
probably screenshotted it showed all my
friends stuff like that you know so uh
I'm I'm excited to you know get get in
the building and get around them you
know he's super funny he's he's he's
going to add some personality to the
team as well so I can't wait to see it
man we got a a team full of
personalities man like and he just he
just adds to the mix and makes it that
much better speaking of adding to the
mix like getting Rosel Douglas on our
team like you know we we got some young
guys we got some young corners but
adding like that veteran Corner um it
could it could be it could be a
Difference Maker for us for sure you we
got guys that's still learning and got
guys that's getting healthy um rasul
just two years ago I remember being like
one of the top corners in the NFL like I
think he was going crazy he might have
led like the NFL at some point Midway
through the season or something but he
was going crazy like with picks and have
him on our team with our defense and our
offense it was it was a great addition
what do you think about it I love it man
I can't wait to see it I can't wait to
you know see what he brings to the team
you know just having another veteran
presence you know on the team that
already has so many vets um I'm I'm just
super excited to see it you know we we
just got back Josh Norman like a week or
two ago as well yeah you know and just
to see that just to see what he already
adds to the team just as a vet who's
been through all of the Rings of the
league um you know it's been interesting
to watch over the past few weeks um and
it's been interesting to get to know him
um and pick his brain a little bit you
know so I'm excited to do the same thing
yeah some other trade some other trade
news we got Chase young going to the San
Francisco 49ers over there with Nick
Bosa like it's it's crazy like I worked
out with I worked out with Chase um in
the offseason this is my second
offseason working out with him man we
work out at dunamis uh Sports and
performance in Colorado Springs with our
guy Chris not and um he does a really
good job like it's one-on-one and our
group it's probably just it was just me
and him and Chris so he's super hands on
the groups are super small love you know
I've seen his growth man and you know he
was he was having a hard time with the
with the with with the commanders and to
see him getting a new start I know what
a new start does for players and you
know he's still a young guy and you know
he has his whole career ahead of him to
be paired up with Nick BOS and they got
Randy Gregory and they got Ken law over
there too and Warner and man they are
they are stag bro what do what do you
think about the the chase young
acquition I love to see it you know um
it's some he's somebody I I've been
watching you know since he was at Ohio
State and it's been dominating so you
know to see him you know get a new start
like you said Fresh Start is everything
sometimes for people
and then also be playing against another
great player Nick Bosa you know it'll
open up opportunities for him to
actually maybe get some one ones or be
able to you know do whatever he can you
know just to add to their team you know
so they over there doing their thing man
they are man I'm I'm excited for him man
I'm excited I'm excited for him Fam I'm
excited for Donovan peoples Jones too
the Detroit Lines they just get better
and better and better they add another
weapon to their team they were already
good and they just get better man
Detroit Lions they have had turnaround
season even last year though like I felt
like the Detroit Lions were a good team
last year like I felt it and I saw it
and to see them take like the STW that
they that they are now they are a
contender in this league for sure after
years of of not being competitive and
now like they are super competitive it's
super cool to see yeah I was um watching
them the other night play and um they
just had glimps to their head coach and
I just remember watching them a few
years ago having the team do like a
crazy amount of up downs during Camp you
know and just to think like the progress
he made since that moment I think that
you know it was he was that was those
back breaker moments where it's like I
got to change the culture of this team
you know what I mean so you know coaches
got to get in and do stuff like that to
be able to have the progress that he's
having so you know I'm just I'm glad to
see that his plan worked out and I'm
definitely glad to see uh dpj get to go
back home you know he's Detroit boy um
somebody that I've known for a while
we've been competing at like camps
Rivals Nike opening you know so like we
go a little bit back you know I know a
bunch of people from from like his high
school MLK ver shout out all of them
boys um you know so to see him get to go
back home um and play for his hometown
that's like a that's probably like a a
kid's dream so I'm super excited for him
speaking of speaking of progress and and
and teams getting better man shout out
to the different Broncos shout out to
Broncos country and Denver Broncos
beating the Chiefs I think it was eight
years like they haven't beat the Chiefs
since since I was there man and like you
know my last couple of years there we
was just getting we were getting we
getting walked on national television
and Patrick Mahomes was having his way
and Travis Kelsey was having his way and
it going crazy and I remember PO he did
like a little they hand the ball off to
PO he did like a little pass over the
top and threw it to I think he threw it
to Kel or somebody and defensive lineman
was was getting uh pass and touchdowns I
think he had a sack in that game too
like they just doing all type of stuff
to the Denver Broncos but not anymore
not any
shout out to the Dem Broncos Russell
Wilson Jerry Judy um uh my guy uh
javante um courin suton can't forget him
my boy deari Mattis deari uh Justin
Simmons um when when uh kjack get out of
jail I know he G to celebrate heavy with
those guys my guy got suspended I guy
got suspended I think they they got to
resend that a little bit though but yeah
that's back to back to back like I mean
like come on there's something players
that you know might play with a little
extra Edge so you know I think it I
think he just get caught in a bad
situation though like he's he going for
the shoulder but it end up he's just so
violent it end up being shoulder helmet
and chest and he end up laying guys out
and they just like you just looking at
it for a surface level was like you
could always call that call if you if
you really if you if you being nitpicky
with it so I think he cuz he's a repeat
offender too like yeah they like he's
not get like he's not he's not listening
he ain't listening but that was the
first time that they beat Kansas City
since Peyton Manning and I were on the
team in 2015 I got a question you was on
the Broncos when y'all played the
Steelers I think it was the first round
of the playoffs yep we should have lost
over time yep both of them should have
lost first play of overtime with TBO TBO
yep do was a slant that's my Ricky
season and 80 yards to the crib first
play over time DT I still get go it
broke my soul wherever I was at
somewhere in Pittsburgh oh yeah cuz
you're a Pittsburgh Fan Man black and
yellow man you know we had to do it to
him man you know what to do it to him I
couldn't I I still can't St and I
watched it a couple weeks ago I don't
know why I don't know what I was talking
about I think I might have watched the
TBO documentary and and U whoever I was
watching it asked about like how long
did TBO play in the league and I um I
like didn't know the number of years or
whatever but like I remember that moment
specifically like he played in the
league sure like
he he ended us right there that I
thought that was a Super Bowl season for
us that was the first year that they
changed the the uh the overtime rules so
if you scored it was over so like when
DT scored like we still had guys on our
sideline getting ready for like the next
drive and then like Tim TBO you see Tim
TBO like shaking hands in the crowd I'm
like what's going on it like it's over
like they the first year they changed
there's the first year they changed the
rules man DT took it to the crib if if
we would have kicked the field goal they
would have got a chance but you know
ended up uh DT took her to the house man
I remember like yesterday he broke off
and then Ike Taylor ik Taylor Ike Taylor
was one of the fastest guys in the
league at the time like so to see him
pull away from Ike like that man it it
was dope I'm getting Goosey on thinking
about it there another time that we
should have lost to the Pittsburgh
selers too in6 2015 on the way to the
playoffs MH so I think it was uh was it
was was the running back uh Mary Mary
menal menal Rashad menal so Rashad mhal
they were Pittsburgh they were on the
way down to go score I think they were
up by three maybe and they were going to
score to put the game up with by 10 yeah
two scores but and it was only like
three minutes left in the game but
Bradley Roby knocked the ball out Roby
and we recover it P Manning goes down
scores a touchdown they get the ball
back we we stop we they go uh four and
out and the game is over I remember that
so it was it was super close so I know
you I know you're a Steelers fan but
yeah that's crazy too Bradley Roby was
my uh he was like a host for me on my
visit to Ohio State that's dope so like
I was like happy to happy for him but I
was Bitter Sweet that and that's that
just shows you bro you just got to keep
playing like Bradley Roy get lucky boom
knocked the ball out and like we go on
to play uh the Patriots the next game we
beat them they had never lost to a team
twice in the season in Tom Brady era we
beat them twice went to the Super Bowl
playing Cam Newton and the Panthers who
were The Underdogs I think it was like
yeah I think it was the spread the
spread margin it was the it was the it
was the widest spread on in Super Bowl
history and we able to go and win that
one we supposed to lose that one but
shout out to the denen Broncos man shout
out to the defense um Patrick ceran all
they played good defense versus the
Chiefs the game before but to put the
offense to had the offense included in
that and you know they just they got Out
Of Reach man and know Patrick Mahomes he
was kind of sick too he was dealing with
the flu but well if you step out there
they say all the time right they say all
the time if you step out there you
belong out there so beat Patrick beat
Patrick Mahomes Travis Kelce the whole
Taylor Swift the whole Taylor Swift
swifties uh the the Swifty they said
they lost cuz she wasn't
there well let's hope she not there
whenever we play a couple of weeks right
um other news Kurt Cousins man he tours
Achilles man you know you hate to see it
um but every great player in this league
you have to overcome if you when you if
you play long enough you're going to
have to overcome some type of adversity
and that adversity could be anything it
could be it could be from your situation
to the situations that I've had in my
career to Kurt Cousins you know you have
to be able to overcome these type of
situations to to be a great player and I
know I I got mad love for Kurt Cousins I
wanted him to come to the Denver Broncos
remember the whole Kurt cousin sweep
Stakes like I was the leader for the
Denver Broncos to get him to to come to
the Denver Broncos he ended up going to
Minnesota and you know I hate to you
know um see him teres Achilles man shout
out to him and his family man you know
you they had the quarterback they had
the quarterback documentary on Netflix
and you just feel like a part of the
journey when you see Kurt Cousins see
and Patrick Mahomes and what is it uh is
uh is that becoming more common it is it
is it's a it's another document they
want say they won't say who they got on
this season of it but they got some more
guys on it to I would love to do
something like that like I would love to
have my my life documented on and and on
Netflix and for for history like on
Netflix forever and ever to play on
Netflix you are introduced to audience
that that normally wouldn't get to see
you and I actually got a documentary
coming up hey man yeah it's going to be
on Netflix who it it's it's still up in
the air on where it's going to be but um
we've been like you know my my marketing
rep Jordan um walked in the hospital you
know like day one or two and would just
asked me like you know you want to roll
the camera I'm like hell yeah you know
because like you know documenting
journey of anything is like that's
that's that's legendary you know that's
the type of things that I look at I I I
I search and want to find like the
people that I you know admire and look
up to I want to see that journey I want
to see every piece of it you know
because there's different things that
you'll be able to relate to you know so
we just had the camera rolling since and
um you know I I would love I would love
to see that man I I would love to I
witness it in person but like Millions
around around the world like I would
want to you know be able to see your
journey in film like that in documentary
format I would would love to see that
man that would be dope man that would be
dope it is um GM vongh you know I love
to play
GM rookie rookie quarterback will
Levis I know I said Levon in the
pre- will will Levis had a big debut he
had 238 yards four touchdowns um he
threw three of them to dehop O you know
deop after the game he said I feel like
Gino I feel like they wrot me off ain't
nobody write you off a nobody CH off DE
everybody know how good you whatever
whatever you know whatever you got to
use his motivation you know we talk
about we talk about that all the timeing
us but it's it's dope to see will Lis
come out there and uh and ball out man
and it's it's crazy news out of Vegas as
well they fired um the
GM they fired uh head coach and they
bench Jimmy G oh they they they changing
some stuff up they going crazy out there
they going crazy and I know I know the I
know the JM I know the GM there I was
you know cuz I want to be a GM and I you
know he bounced some ideas off of me and
I was able to spend time with him at Max
Crosby's wedding um he's done a great
job over there I don't see maybe you
know people they see stuff that I don't
and obviously it was time for a change
but I know he'll have another shot in
the league and you know maybe uh maybe
the head coach he goes back to to the
Patriots you think he's done it before
yeah who knows you know what I'm say you
think he go back
midseason that's probably tough right
ain't that probably tough I I mean we SE
we seen I I don't think it's a rule
against though I don't think it's he's
out if you technically look at it like
he's out of work and they just make a
hire yeah so you know who knows but I
mean I think they got like a you know a
certain type of tree over there that
everyone kind of they they funnel their
people through so I going to be
surprised if we return back home Jimmy G
getting benched though that was that was
probably the most surprising out all of
this stuff cuz he is their guy he is
their franchise quarterback and no
matter how bad the franchise quarterback
is playing you you you know you you ride
with him especially when you got a
receiver like Devon Adams that was
probably the most shocking to me to see
that where do they go where do they go
from there uh I don't know who's on
their roster I don't know who they they
benched them for but I I think it is a
little bit you know I think it is unique
that they they benched Jimmy G um I I
look he been a Jimmy G fan since he was
uh up in with the 49ers yeah I I I seen
him as one of the elite quarterbacks you
know and then being able to see him play
you know I'm like okay getting to see
him play for myself I'm like okay you
know getting to watch how our game went
you know and it's was like you know when
you got a prime time receiver you know
you got to got to find ways give him the
ball you got to give him the ball you
got to give him the ball you that means
benching Jimmy G then then so be but I
mean I'm not a Raiders fan by any means
but I feel for Raiders Nation because it
was they has so much potential this
season they had so much potential they
have a really good team offensive line
is good uh Jacobs is a great running
back got receivers um Defense Max
Crosby um they're they're stacked and to
see them struggle man you know I feel
for Raiders n Nation kind of yeah I was
I think I think like same thing you
saying I feel you know I feel like
they've been expected to have great
years you know every year since like the
little bit of time that they signed AB
back a few years ago and it was like
okay Raiders you know they they got bro
D AB they were supposed to go crazy with
AB they were supposed to go crazy with
AB then AB end up leaving or whatever
happened um you know so it's like I feel
like every year since then they've been
expecting to have a good year so yeah
then we got guys like Max Crosby too man
I I I've seen firsthand how hard Max
Crosby Works he comes to my pastor I've
been to his his uh his football camp in
in Dallas like you know I've got to know
him over the years like you know and
this that word deserve is like tricky
because we all feel like we deserve it
but he puts in the work man he puts in
all the things that that are necessary
to have success man and you know he he
deserves it just like everybody else man
but I've witnessed Max Crosby work man
and hopefully it'll come soon not before
us though not before the both B but
hopefully soon man um on the Sunday
night on to Sunday night foot uh
football man this is our second time
playing on Sunday night man I always um
love playing on Prime Time games um
whether it's Thursday night Monday night
Sunday night when the whole world's
watching that's why we that's why we
play the game for stages like this um
Joe Burl is looking like old self um
he's coming off of w versus the 49ers
that was a big win cuz the 49ers are a
really good team they're stacked all
over the place and to see Joe barl and
the guys ball out against the uh the
49ers was huge yeah uh I'm excited man
I'm super excited man to you know walk
back in here and Sunday Night Football
man it's going to be super electric you
know
uh last two games we played them you
know what I mean so we got a uh we we we
we got some look back to get you know
what I mean so we we got an exciting
week ahead of us what do you think we
need to do to win this one I know coach
M he always say man complimentary
football um which is true um you know be
tight on all three phases make the team
one dimensional what does Demar Hamlin
think by you know being in a locker and
being around the guys um what do you
think we need to do to win this one uh I
think we need to start fast I think I
think we need to come out with a chip on
our shoulder like a little Edge you know
we we always play best when we got that
spark behind us and we play a little
angry you know what I mean so you know
we just got to just take an extra energy
extra enthusiasm whatever it may be like
Co like whatever whatever you need you
know what I mean to to get you in that
mindset for that for that moment you
know but one thing about us we always
show up you know we always show up for
them big moments you know so Sunday
night we we know what's at stake we know
where we going um you know we know who's
on our team and we know the situation of
everything you know what I mean so I
think we going to have that exactly what
we need to go get it done man you you've
come a long way man I've seen you grow
up and just U less than a year bro and
you know to call you my teammate and
call you my brother man it's super
special to me man I'm proud of you man
um going back to Cincinnati this week
you know how's it how's it going to feel
returning to that Stadium I think it's
going to be super electric I mean I
think it's going to be nothing but love
you know just I mean only thing I got to
compare it to is just going back into
our stadium and how much love and and
reception it is you know so going back
into there I'm pretty sure it'll be like
a a bunch of uh like you know
memories which will you know that'll
make it emotional for me um you know but
I ain't running from it I'm I'm ready to
walk through the fire um but I think
other than that man I think it's going
to be all love I think it's going to be
all energy all support um I'm I'm super
excited to see it I remember just
watching on TV from the hospital just
seeing the stadium um when we played the
the Patriots um and even with the
dolphins uh you know just right after
everything happened and it was like
electric like the atmosphere was
electric so you know I think it'll be on
that same level and same atmosphere so
you know I'm I'm super excited um I'm
thankful man I'm blessed and I'm I'm
just appreciative on both ends of the
support from everybody in Cincinnati the
team the fans everyone showed my family
love while they were there for you know
a whole week and um you know just
everybody on our and man just all the
Bros we got uh all the support staff
trainers upstairs you know everybody
that we got just it's all of on both
both ends you know what I mean so it's
like kind of like I I feel like it's
kind of like you know when you go to
that family reunion and get to see both
sides of the family who you know you get
all love from so you know but like you
told me man one thing that Just Let Me
ease my mind even off of like all the
emotions and thinking about like the you
know all of the like the memories that's
going to come from just even coming back
into the stadium and uh you know just
just the emotions of like trying to
handle the media all week and navigating
all of that you know just you just
giving me that little just man you
already won like that just allowed me to
just rest assured and just have fun with
it like you know what I'm saying the the
literally like the hard part's already
over so you know it's it's really about
nothing when you when you think of it
like that man you you are blessed um
beyond all measure on the football field
off the football field man it's number
but love from Cincinnati it's number but
love from Buffalo and I can speak from
for all type of fans all across the
world it's nothing but love for Demar
Hamlin man I appreciate you for coming
on my show man if you ever need me man
you know I got you man all love and
respect man Chason M man let's do it man
love
[Music]
man